this world today this aside today
they're a little bit different
and then they even challenge what god
say
they say if god put you in here with
male organs you still may be a female
kind of crazy to me because god put you
in what you want what do you want you to
be
we don't have a chance just like y'all
let me come in dark and i can't go say
i'm white
well how can i come with me organ though
and say i'm female that's not fair
enough is it
because if i can come in with male
organs and be treated as a female
that should be to come as a black person
and be treated as a white man
if that's what i want if i can choose
everything right
that's the only thing i'm saying i'm not
against it but why not make it all the
way around the board if you don't do it
if you come as a male and be a female or
a female to be a male
then why can't come as a black and be a
white because i get much better
treatment
you understand me there's a lot more me
to get in there so
along that line if you go from 100 to
and i go from 154 to 226
that's what the guy weighed am i not
covering more weight than you so does it
not give me
certified me as truly pound found the
best
see we don't face the facts no more we
like to cover things up and act like oh
no
then why why is it not because if you
can change that
why can't i change this and if it's
powerful pound
then why not the person that covered the
most weight why why is it that he not
found the best and everybody asks he
covered the most weight
why he ain't pumped by the it's as good
an best
as anyone saying how that would agree
with the facts all i'm saying
you